Been good. It's been a month.
Good, good. Yeah, it didn't kick me out of the meeting, so we're already a step better than last time we tried.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, so they did some policy change at the domain level. That's broke a few things, so they fixed it eventually.
Nice, nice.
So, how is it going?
How was your week so far?
If.
It's been a week. Yeah, I'm just trying to get stuff wrapped up today. It's been busy, so.
Yeah.
Our admin called out today, so it's picking up a lot of that slack too, so.
Team.
Yeah, great.
Fun stuff, yeah.
Any plans for this weekend?
Not really. I have a conference next week, kind of just hitting on a lot of our cybersecurity tools. It's through Kaseya. So that's next week in Las Vegas. So I am flying out Monday and I'm going to be out of town all week. So just kind of getting ready for that.
Okay.
Okay, okay, great.
So, how's Keith doing?
He's doing really well, I think. I think he's doing good.
Any feedback for him? Anything where he needs improvement?
Um...
No, not. I mean, I don't think so. Everything he's been doing is good. It's nothing major that needs improvement, no.
Okay, thank Kour.
You might have received a CX survey for the month of March, so do take on some time and fill that out for Casey.
Oh, sure.
Yes, I can, I can do that.
All right, so let's quickly jump in to the presentation and let's look at his numbers.
That I can do.
Are you able to see my screen?
Yes.
Okay, great. Once again, welcome to our monthly business review. This is from March 23rd till April 17th.
So agenda would be the same, no change, checking, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis for Casey, who is of your customer, view forward and recap.
We already talked about how things are moving and thank you for sharing the feedback with Casey and we really appreciate it.
And in the highlights, he's performing well, consistent, proactive engagement and ownership of assigned work. He's actively handling tickets, escalated tickets, and also supporting project activities.
like email migration and all, and he's been handling the projects execution with multiple clients and independently managing the onboarding task as well. We discussed about the KPI framework in our NAS Connect and the CSAT survey I already mentioned. So whenever you get time, take on.
Fill that out for Casey.
Yeah, I will.
Moving on to the action tracker. So to identify KPIs to better gauge Casey's performance, this is something we need to work on, to look into regarding the certification. He is.
He was a bit off track due to some personal stuff going on in his family. His mother was not keeping well, so he was a little occupied there, so he couldn't get much time to.
Yeah.
Hope on it, but he will be completing this by the end of May.
Okay, perfect.
And I was able to identify some KPIs based on the project work he does.
So like one time delivery rate on budget delivery, rework rate, documentation, quality, stakeholder satisfaction. So any of these works for you to track his performance.
I think I'll run that through Dylan. I don't, he's got to set up the KPIs on that. If you want to send a short email to him with that, he can get that started.
Yeah.
Sure, sure. I will send this VPT and I will also mention about the KPIs as well.
Perfect.
And let's jump into the performance analysis. This is his utilization for the last four weeks. So he's been pretty close to 82% on an average. In the third week, he almost reached 94%. So as I mentioned, he's working on the tickets as well as the projects.
So, um...
Considering this 82% utilization, so...
Do you need or do you think that there is a need for another additional or another resource that?
Can we can help you with?
Um...
No, I don't think so.
Okay.
But do let us know in case you feel like there is another resource that is required. So we can definitely help you out on that.
OK.
And this is his ticket data. He pulled on 143 tickets and closed 56. So yeah.
His ticket count appears low because most of the tickets he work on are the project tickets, migrations, and infra changes, so...
Yeah.
Kip.
Way forward Casey to proactively reach out whenever he has less tickets to work on.
And...
This is the Build It Live 2026. We are going to have a session in August, from August 3rd till 5. And we will share these details with Dylan as well.
Kour.
So, you can also take out some time if you can, and you can attend this session, so it's pretty amazing.
I know in August we have an AI conference that we have to go to.
Mmh.
But...
Yeah, definitely send the information on it, and...
We will look it over.
Sure.
Yeah, Natalie will follow up as well, so no problem.
Okay.
So this is the AI by design, you already aware, and this is the Team GPS, so you already know.
Rick.
So, that's it.
Anything that is known you want to share, suggest?
Sweet.
I don't think so. Things have been going smooth. Yeah, Casey's doing good. I don't have really anything other than good things to say about him.
Okay, great. Thank you. Thank you for your time, Tanner, on this call today. And yeah, you don't have to wait for a month to wait for another call in case you have any feedback to share, but you can feel free to reach out to me over the email and I will be more than.
No problem.
I'm happy to help you out.
Rick.
All right, well, that's perfect. Yeah, thanks, Kip. You have a good rest of your day. Have a good weekend.
Thank you, Tina, for your time. Yep. Yep. Thank you. Bye bye.
You too, bye bye.
Bye.